hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer der verstörendsten
websites aller zeiten unser bin ich
heute mal wieder auf der website z 0 er
unterwegs und m
man bekommt da quasi irgendwelche random
websites einfach zugewiesen
das ist alles die erste mal
zurückhaltend wie mickey mouse donald
duck goofy und dagobert duck schauen ein
quadrat hier sehen wir wie ein
ladebalken voll
das ist nicht wahr minister bekommen
denn jetzt 21 seite wo die beklauten sie
kommt von pinguin acer
entschärft
doch dieses papiers ist ich bin froh
dass wir noch nicht was hatten was wir
bei einem der letzten mal hatten und
zwar hatten wir da einen hund der graben
befriedigt wird und dabei kotzt das
video für euch mal hier das schaut euch
das aber nur an wenn ihr da wäre wenn
ihr das schaut euch einfach nicht an
hier haben wir das tatsächlich irgendwie
was macht also bei allem respekt so
warum will sie dass es doch das ist doch
der typ tanz vor und zurück mit seinem
das tue ich hier
wie
also ich weiß nicht wie lange wir lila
schnur da um ihren bau besser waren
scheint unendlich ich weiß man nie was
ich zettel näher kommentieren soll weil
natürlich da denn jetzt sagen ja
herzlich willkommen zur techno leer wir
sehen hier gerade zwei mädels die etwas
weg laut man sie laufen beginnt das den
rasen und sinnvoll schnell und
wahrscheinlich verfolgt jemand und die
eine ist sogar traurig und die andere
guckst um
ich krieg mal auf next jetzt haben wir
gerade ein video von spongebob hier in
ruhe patrick
oh mein gott endlich haben wir eine
website gefunden die wirklich ein wenig
leistet freunde wir haben irgendein tier
was was um diese einen baum herum läuft
und zwar die ganze zeit und das ist
nicht zusammen geschnitten sondern es
ist läuft tatsächlich wirklich gerade
einfach darum wie das geld ja es wurde
noch kein mal geschnitten und sie läuft
immer noch darum das ist ja ein
unfassbares alte vermögen alter
nein
ich glaube ich sollte man lieber gehen
slater ich weiß echt lange zeit weg
schaut sich das ganze
es hat sicherlich schon wieder weg was
soll das freunde wir sind wieder bei
einer hypnose website gelandet wir
hatten das schon mal mit der hypnose das
verlinkt ich hier
wenn ich nicht vergesse dass dazu
verlinken da ich solche webseiten hass
und davon einmal voll
damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet
werden euch das video gefallen an meine
damen und herren würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freuen da das immer diese
tonding spuren sich seit 40 jahre lang
und das schneide ich halt irgendwie
runter weil halt voll viel crepes sap
wenn ihr wirklich gerade noch dran seid
dann schreibt man die kommentare luca
wird nächster kanzler von deutschland
tschüss